من معبر باب الهوى مازن علوش مدير
العلاقات الاعلاميه والمتحدث باسم اداره
معبر باب الهوى استاذ مازن يعني السؤال
الاساسي الان هو هل المعبر مفتوح بطريقه
كامله
وطرقات صالحه لتمرير الامدادات من هناك كل
ما تحتاجه المنطقه الشماليه في سوريا
مساء الخير لكل الساده المشاهدين طبعا
الجهتين من طرف التركي لم يتاخر ابدا
بالزلزال ولا حسب الطرق المؤديه اليه لكن
لم تصل لدينا اي مساعدات اضافيه بكافه
منذ لحظه
الزلزال حتى تاريخ اليوم نحن في مساء
اليوم الثالث لهذه المقاسات التي ضربت
الشعب السوري
استاذ مازن يعني كان هناك
تصريحات متضاربه حول يعني حول اتحدث عن
ظروف المعبر البعض يقول بان الطرقات هالكه
لا يمكن ان تمر عليها مساعدات اللازمه
التي تحتاج المنطقه الشماليه والبعض يقول
بان الطرقات صالحه ونحن بانتظار وصول
مساعدات اي من هاتين يعني من هذين
التصريحين هو الاصح
ان كل الطرقات صالحه
علما منذ اليوم الاول للزلزال حتى تاريخ
اليوم نحن خلال ثلاثه ايام المعبر مفتوح
فقط امام استقبال الجنازات السوريين
الذين هم يقيمون لاجئين في الاراضي
التركيه
السوريين السيارات تنقلهم من عده الولايات
الى ما ضربه بالهواء
الى دفهم في المناطق المحرره سوريا فكيف
نفسها هي
صالحه للعبور السيارات النقل الموتى وليس
الصالحه لعبور النقل المساعده مع العلم ان
المساعد ان الامم المتحده مستودعاتها
الرئيسيه هي تكون في مدينه الريحانيه
تركيا تبعد عن النظر سوى واحد كيلو متر
وهي هذه المستودعات مليئه بالاصل قبل
الاحداث الزلزال بيوم واحد كانت القوافل
تدخل بشكل دوري بعد قرار مجلس الامن
الاخير بتمديد دخول المساعده
نحن نشرنا هو ان ابوابنا المساعدات في
اليوم التالي صباح البارحه الامين المتحده
ان هنالك الطرق في المعبر من الجانب
التركي غير ذلك
نحن ايضا مفتوحه قبل قليل تصريف لوزير
الخارجيه التركي ان الطرق داخل سوريا غير
سالبه فلا اعلم
ايضا يعني تصريح الرسم التركي يقول بان
سوري بان تركيا مستعده لفتح معبرين
اضافيين مع سوريا هل هناك تنسيق معكم على
يعني على مداخل وتخوم الشمال السوري واين
ستكون هذه المعابر
لا لنا عن الامر نحن كل ما نعلمه ان معظم
باب الهوى مفتوح
على مدار 24 ساعه نحن نقوم باستقبال جثث
اهلنا فقط لا يوجد استقبال لاي مساعدات او
اي فرق تطوعيه او اضافيه او مشاكل ميدانيه
او الى ذلك
السيارات بامكانها الوصول الى المعبر بكل
سهوله من الجهتين الطرق لو سمحت اليوم
يعني الشمال السوري بمرحله سباق مع الوقت
خصوصا ان كل ساعه تاخير تكلف اكثر من 50
ضحيه هل ممكن ان تطلق صرخه للمجتمع الدولي
لكل من يتذرع بان الطرقات غير صالحه
والمعبر غير مفتوح وبالتالي لا يمكننا
ايصال المساعدات الى شمال سوريا واذا كان
هناك من عوائق من يعيق دخول هذه المساعدات
صراحه يعني كان هنالك جلسه قبل قليل بيني
وبين الجانب التركي
قال التركي انهم
كل المعبرين سيكون جاهزين
لكن
لننتظر ولنرى هل
من الصحيح ستلبي الامم المتحده الاحتياجات
السوريه المنكوبين ام لا انا اؤكد لك انه
حتى تاريخ اللحظه لا يوجد اي دخول لاي
مساعدات لدينا
الاف العوائل تشردت مئات العوائل ما زلت
تحت الانقاض خلال لمده اكثر من ساعه لدينا
نقص كبير في المعدات خاصه معدات التي تسحب
بازاله الانقراض
كبيره من الجهود شعبيه هنالك تضامن كبير
جدا على المستوى الشعبي على مستوى الحكومي
على المستوى
العسكر نحن نتحدث عن كار على مستوى
الاستجابه الدوليه والانسانيه لكل
احتياجات بالمنطقه الشماليه اذا باختصار
لو سمحت اذا ما سالنا عن موضوع الاصابات
الاحتياجات الطبيه هناك ما الذي يحصل كيف
هي الصوره على الارض
الفتره قبل الزلزال كل الحالات الحرجه
التي لا نستطيع ان نذهب كانت تخرج للعلاج
في مسافه تركيا
وحتى تاريخ اليوم توقف ايضا خروج المرضى
والحالات السعوديه البارده للعلاج التركيه
فالاعتماد حاليا هو فقط على كوادر
الموجوده في المنطقه من الاطباء والمشاكل
الميدانيه وغيرها التي هي لا تختصر لكل
شيء يعني لو الله ثم التبرعات لتاتي من
السوريين المغتربين والتجار الموجودين في
المناطق هنا
والتمويل الحكومي
في حكومه انقاذ وغيرها
قمنا بماسات كبيره جدا يعني اما على مستوى
الدولي لم يصلنا اي شيء الدعم كله يصب اما
في صالح النظام نرى ان الدول الحديثه
للنظام تقوم بمجده
بالتيارات الاغاثيه
في تركيا اما هنا اكثر من اربع ملايين من
مواطن منكوبين على مدار اقناع شرعا من
تاريخ الثوره زاد عليهم هزه تمثال لا يوجد
لدينا اي اغاثه تردنا مع اننا نحن بامثل
الحاجه لاي شيء يصل الى المنطقه اي شيء
كان بكل
شكرا لك استاذ مازن علوش مدير العلاقات
الاعلاميه والمتحدث باسم اداره معبر باب
الهوى على هذه المداخله وعلى هذه الصرخه
الانسانيه التي اطلقتها من هناك